Well, hi everyone. I wanted to take a few minutes to share with you our vision for the
new church that we're launching on Sunday, November 3rd, in the Sachse-Garland area.
And this video, it's going to be a little bit lengthy. It will have three parts. Part
one, I will share our vision. Part two, I'll share our values. And then in part three,
I'll share details on the where and when and how you can get involved, if you're so inclined.
So let's start with part one, the vision. So it seems to me that the great temptation,
and perhaps this is true of any age, but specifically of our age, is that we're very tempted to
be incredibly reactionary, right? And I think this is true at both the micro and the macro
level. Let's start with the micro or like the individual level. At the micro level,
because we're human, we are tempted to operate from an incredibly reactionary place, right?
We're tempted to operate from the worst version of ourselves, right? We're shot through with
anxiety, and what if, and so we react. We are stressed out, and so we react. We're afraid,
and so we react. In fact, if you look at your own life and the lives of others, you probably
see this reactionary posture all over the place. By the way, this is what the Bible
calls sin, because it's bad. It hurts people, right? We hurt people. I hurt people. However,
when it gets crazy is when this starts to play out at the macro level. You see, in our
culture, in our politics, in our religious institutions, we have some very loud voices
that are basically 24-7 fear, outrage, and anger machines. And what this is leading to
is an incredible level of polarization, right? It's us against them. My people versus your
people. My religion versus your religion. My political group versus your political group.
And unfortunately, many churches and church leaders, rather than opposing this, seem
to be joining right in, right? They say, there is a culture war, and sadly, a lot of Christians
and folks are like the people banging the war drums the loudest. And I believe that's
a tragedy, but it's a sign that we live in a reactionary age. Okay, so what's the good
news here? Well, I believe that this church community we're launching has a tremendous
opportunity to be an oasis of calm in the midst of the storm, a light in the darkness.
Because while the culture wants us to go to war with one another, we are going to choose
instead to gather at the table. That's the name of our church, the table. I want you
to think of a table. What is a table a picture of? Well, it's a lot of things, right? It's
a picture of family. It's a picture of community, right? It's a picture of love and of sharing,
of food, and it's a picture of a place where enemies can listen to one another, understand
one another, right? It's a picture of a place where I can know and be known, where I can
seek to understand and be understood. It's a place where I can learn, as the message
version, the paraphrase of the Bible says, I can learn the unforced rhythms of grace.
And if you place the table in the context of a church, well then that table becomes
much more than simply a regular old table. It becomes the table of the Lord Jesus, the
Jesus who said, love your enemies and pray for those who persecute you. The Jesus who
was the friend of sinners, the Jesus who, as the writer Jean Leclerc said, he ate good
food with bad people. I love that. The Jesus who said, why are you anxious? Don't you know
that God loves you and sees you? The Jesus who died and rose again to draw all people
to himself. The Jesus who, on the night he was betrayed, stood at what? A table and said,
this bread is my body, broken for you. This wine is my blood, shed for you. Remember me.
Remember me, never forget. So this is who we are, as an organization and as a church.
The table exists to shift a generation from reactionary to visionary, to the person in
work of Jesus. You see, what the world needs is visionary people. People who can say, I
don't have to be insecure. I don't have to be afraid. I don't have to be alone, because
the God I've come to know in Jesus is love. And I'm his child. And I have a church community
that expresses that and reminds me of that in everything we say and do. Okay, so that's
part one. Part two is our core values. So this starts to name, what on earth are the
values that will actually keep us aligned with this vision? So here at the table we
have five values. Number one, thoughtful. Number two, inclusive. Three, eclectic. Four,
communal. Number five, vulnerable. Okay, so let's unpack these. Number one, I said, is
thoughtful. We are a community that values a thoughtful approach to life. We're okay
with things taking a little bit of time. We want to go a little bit slowly. We want to
think it through. We want to weigh the cost of our words and the implications of our actions.
You see, to be thoughtful means that there are no questions or issues that we are unwilling
to tackle. Instead, we seek to mirror both the calm and the depth of Christ, for whom
nothing was off limits. Number two is the value for being inclusive. So we are a radically
inclusive community. You see, the reactionary mind is constantly searching for an enemy
to exclude, but we keep searching for new people to bring to the table. We keep stretching,
stretching, stretching the definitions of who might be valued and welcomed into God's
kingdom. So no matter what socioeconomic bracket, your racial identity, sexual orientation,
mental facility, or moral standing, we want to create a table big enough to hold everyone.
Number three is eclectic. Now, radical inclusivity means that we want to live into that, the
tension of that, that difference creates, and we want to celebrate the beautiful chaos
of it all. This means we are a remarkably eclectic community. We think there's beauty
in bringing unexpected people, unexpected ideas, and traditions of Christianity together
because it's in that place of creative tension that new life happens. That's why we want
and we need people of differing theologies, politics, personalities, and giftedness in
one community. Sure, it's super uncomfortable at times, but we're all better off for it
because without the new and the different, we cannot stretch and grow.
Number four, communal. We are a church devoted to the principles of communion. See, to participate
in communion is to lean into the mystery of Christ's present nearness. As a communal church,
we are committed to being present to one another, to allow the depth that is fostered in being
in communion with one another to resonate out into the world around us. We believe that
to be in communion with one another is to participate in the restorative, renewing life
of Christ.
Core value number five is vulnerable. This is a hard one, but it's absolutely essential.
See, we are a church that is committed to vulnerability as it is. It's basically the
linchpin to all of our other values. It takes vulnerability to be introspective in the way
that thoughtfulness requires. It takes vulnerability to allow the risks and challenges in the way
inclusivity requires. It takes vulnerability to do the work of synthesizing eclectic ideas
and making room for the ways that our assumptions will be challenged when we do that. And it
takes vulnerability to foster the kind of depth and relational intimacy that communion
inspires.
Okay, so that is part two of our core values. The third and final part is the details, the
where, the when, the how. Okay, so where are we meeting? Well, the plan right now is that
we will be renting a space at a church in Sachse, Texas at 5 p.m. on Sunday evenings.
I can't yet say which church because we haven't inked that contract, but we're very close
to finalizing it. So, Sachse, Texas. When will we begin meeting? Our first public service
will be Sunday, November 3rd. I'm pumped.
All right, how? How can you be a part? Well, there's three ways. First, join the launch
team. The launch team are people who say more than, I will attend. They say, I will pray,
serve, give. In essence, these are the people who say, look, I believe in what you're doing
and I want to be in at the ground level, helping to make it a reality.
There may be those who say, though, well, that sounds like a lot. I'm not sure I can
be a part of the launch team, but I still want to help. All right, second option, you
can attend. Like I said, we'll be launching November 3rd, and so if you want to stay in
the loop on that, simply kick me an email at brettatthetabletx.com or direct message
me via like really any social media outlet. Third, of course, you can give. I'll link
to our giving page below, but if this is a vision that you really believe in, then we
would greatly appreciate your support. Okay, I hope you enjoyed this video. Please like
it, share it, and remember, stay humble, stay kind. God bless.